well another day another lie from our
esteemed
climate czar john kerry for years he
swore he never
tried to undermine the trump state
department by holding back channel
meetings
with iran here he is in 2019
i saw the foreign minister briefly for a
few minutes at the
munich security conference but i have
not said a word subsequently to what
they ought to do or not do it's not my
business and i don't engage in any
diplomacy on it now there's been no back
channeling
no i haven't had any back channel on
that issue since the decision was made
to move out
but wouldn't you know it turns out kerry
wasn't being so truthful according to a
new report
current biden officials including robert
malley and john kerry himself
met with iranian foreign minister havaad
zarif multiple times over the course of
three years
with the explicit intent of undermining
president trump's foreign policy agenda
in iran here with me now former
secretary of state mike pompeo
and a hudson institute distinguished
fellow mr secretary thank you so much
for being here
you know i looked at back at my calendar
and it was actually a year ago today
that you were returning from a big trip
to oman
saudi arabia africa and the munich
security council meeting
and at that munich security council
meeting we saw
john kerry there and we also saw the
iranians there and we knew that there
were back channels going on
but they were lying about it and now i
want to get your response to
this new admission
katie it's great to be with you i
remember that trip and i remember seeing
ernie moniz and secretary kerry all
there
we knew this was going on and frankly we
knew it was going on before that as well
it's un-american it's very troubling
it's not the right thing to do
they lost an election and they should
have just gotten off the stage
they chose not to do that and instead
tried to undermine what the american
people
had put forward as america's policy and
a policy frankly that kept america safe
but in the end the good news is our
policy in the middle east was successful
we built out a strong coalition to crush
the regime in iran
we built out a gulf state set of
coalition partners that signed abraham
accords creating
peace and stability throughout the
middle east our policies work it's sad
that
secretary kerry is so so unable to get
off the stage at any point
that he had to go try and undermine what
president trump and our team were trying
to do
yeah iran's a big topic right now the
the vitamin white house is reaching out
to iran without any preconditions
national security advisor jake sullivan
was doing an interview over the weekend
and want to get your response to what he
had to say
he's prepared to go to the table to talk
to the iranians
about how we get strict constraints back
on their nuclear program
iran has not yet responded it is iran
that is isolated now diplomatically not
the united states
and the ball is in their court seems
like the ball is in their court
a lot they get to kick out inspectors
they get to enrich uranium
where are we with iran at this point
okay the sad thing is they're going to
have more balls they're going to have
money they're going to have wealth
they're going to have the capacity crate
tier all across the world
this is what the previous administration
did for eight years when i hear
president biden say we're going back we
america can't afford to go back to what
they were doing with iran
they built up their missile program that
created capabilities that threatened the
world
that's not the back america wants us to
get to that's
dangerous but it looks like this
administration is headed down that path
they've
apparently spoken to the chinese and the
russians although not to congress
about their intentions they haven't also
spoken in an important way with the
countries that matter most
our gulf state partners there in the
region and the israelis who have a deep
security interest remember they're the
little satan we're the big satan
that the iranians continue to this day
to threaten that's who we need to work
with those are the partners that you
build out of security alliance and
that's the coalition that can keep
americans safe yeah i want to get your
take on that a little further because
when we talk about the iranians we're
not just talking about
the country of iran we're talking about
their proxy groups talk about their
terrorist organizations all over the
world
talk about why this is a threat to the
everyday american why should they care
if the biden administration goes back
into a nuclear deal or not
we saw this during the jcpoa before we
had withdrawn we saw them launch
missiles
that put americans who were traveling
abroad at risk right they launched
missiles into places where americans
travel
but we also saw their capacity to reach
out here into the united states for
don't forget
they tried to kill the saudi ambassador
right in washington d.c
this is a regime that now for 40 years
has committed some of the most egregious
terror violations all across the world
and whether it's lebanese hezbollah that
threatens israel
or the shia militias in iraq that
threaten iraqi citizens and american
soldiers we've seen three attacks
during the buy administration that i
haven't seen any response to yet that
were
almost certainly supported by the
iranian regime those are the kind of
things that threaten america
the iranians understand one thing katie
they understand seriousness and
deterrence and when
qasim suleimani threatened america we
crushed him that's what the iranians
understand when we appease
when we give them money when we kowtow
they only understand that's a way for
them to continue down the path towards a
nuclear program
and to build out their terror campaign
one final question here i want to switch
over to china the chinese foreign
minister today is
asking for the biden administration to
reset relations to take
sanctions off to to have meetings about
how they can work together you have the
president biden talking about china
being a strong
competitor what is your response to
those two things
well by administration to date has been
all over the lot i hope they'll get this
right this is the most important
challenge for our generation and the
next one
but the chinese too they only understand
strength when you spy on americans we'll
close your consulate
when you undermine promises to the
people of hong kong we're going to
sanction your leaders
that's how our administration responded
this one needs to do the same
all right secretary of state mike pompeo
thank you so much we appreciate it thank
you katie have a good evening
thanks